I'm not racing Portland Oregon him time
God left and then when I left I wrote a
stepfather I did meet my first my father
he tried to have sex with me
I'm glad father that I hadn't already
been molesting down Oh didn't bother me
as much as some things later in life
bothered me a little bit more of it I
met my father when my mother got with
another pedophile who could not have
female minors live in the home he had
just raped his blood daughter and he had
gotten released he's dead now name was
Manuel owner and he was on parole didn't
have happy my mines living in the house
so I went to live with my Grammy well I
was very close with and my mom called my
dad who was in Nevada and I'm in Bali
and he came out they drove out there he
was on drugs honey I mean I knew what it
was from like TV shows but I had never
had did see him somebody actually do it
he hit him his fourth wife she was
pregnant he is about 12 kids I just have
friends sisters me out
my father's life we need to pray in it
in the labor she went to the hospital he
went with her
there was only two small children's
their destiny who's uh who supposedly
it's rumored that he killed my behalf
sitters destiny her mama they got into a
fight should have a gun and he struggled
there was a struggle for the gun the gun
went off she got shot
destiny was there they took testing
anyway 20min jail
I'm kidding the charges they said it was
self-defense but and she was shot he had
plenty of time to call an ambulance for
her he went until she bled out and then
he called that's what I heard so when
she been into labor the next wife fourth
wife went into labor with Christopher
James that's my brother um he came back
home to the house I was asleep I played
like I sleep to my other step by step
daddy when I was a little girl he all
the time he'd pick me up and carry me to
my bed so I just pretend I'm clean and
my only reason I knew it wasn't my be
able to there was water bed and he said
you want me to take his clothes off and
show you something really nice just turn
over Oscar II down there like a bat out
of hell
and ran over sent to my room the rooms
were next to each other it was in Nevada
and I lost the door and I thought about
going out the window but I didn't done
next day he put me on a bus back to
order anyone
you call nobody either when I got there
it was in the middle of the night I had
to walk all the way to my friends
downtown Portland or him to 33rd and
Prescott yeah I've been through a lot
I am on my way out of Oregon
I met a pimp named Charlie soft and he
took me down here by Disneyland until
8:00
I was 12 when I first started by 15 I
had met Memphis slim ninja slim I fell
in love with him but I I don't think he
loved anybody ever he was more about
ninety many many many many even
sometimes I come home yeah one day I
made 500 dollars in two hours
I seen him driving by upside come down a
sack SIG's whole day off look what I got
it do you think well no they give the
rs500 I said that what you don't look
like it to me let me count again and the
slowly 20 it was 500 but he would never
take it from a tan to hand you have to
set it down somewhere and he pick it up
we had an apartment out here in Studio
City but we never did get a stove
refrigerator with the Matt and I can
cook at that age I have it's pregnant
that hand he had me have an abortion and
I hit the first one I kinda got him
twice I had my first abortion by him in
and in sonido in Sunita I think it was
coke and in Colorado Springs where his
brother was actually arrested for
pending and pandering he his brother and
his whole family was in the pimp and Ho
game they have a talk it's different
than English
husbands in pig latin it's like I was
saying who are you
it'd be like his New Year's New Year's
new who are you like um up and down is
now Disney
it's a it's a pen hoe talk the language
oh I came back to California became a
South Sider from the west side whether
those orphans I'm from Oh PHS my name is
Flavia acai and I have gangbangs for
quite some time because nobody sees me
coming allegedly yeah and then I got
with a Michael um no no I got with me I
got a cartoon my homeboy first and hit
my daughter as my daughter's by him and
then I met Michael I got out of prison
after so he 13 years on a 15 year
sentence I um I was accused of doing 36
armed robberies being the driver many of
them would dismissed
I took a plea deal my co-defendant took
20 years came back down gave detailed
testimony and signed affidavit and warsi
hearing and because of that they dropped
his time from 20 to 12 I had to take the
deal I could not fight it any longer
because I would have been convicted and
got a life sentence so I served 13 years
flat I hit all three prisons i paroled
from GOP which is in ciaw now I just
recently got off parole yeah you me yeah
no second type of it but the first time
they were so far apart I forgot about
the penalty I'll never forget again 13
years flat awake you up now son was five
months old my daughter had just turned
five I had to my son is raised by his
father who is well hell I might as well
be honest about it
he's my mother-in-law's husband and we
had sex on the sofa and I produced a son
from it I regret it I loved her I don't
know how I did it I messed up in the
head
things the right way and I love right
night-night no ring that loves me I
totally tell you how sorry oh but I
think father-in-law I live in a tent I
got with Michael Michael brought me down
here I never been past the side of the
freeway too good for my name isn't when
I Bank is over in that area
I've also prostitute it recently because
I have to support myself it's very hard
especially it's getting ready rain I
have no top my tent my tent has no door
that closes I've put something in front
of it
but you I have to have a big tent I
can't be bending over trying to scoot on
stuff I got a diabetic neuropathy and
I'm oldest dirt so sorry you say but
give me a big big ten I will be 15 in
March I quit for a long time stop it now
I have that telling my secret yes I did
I've dogs actually I've just 70 recently
I took a Greyhound bus Memphis slim put
me on a greyhound to go to the Olympics
in Vancouver BC and now this was in the
80s oh it had it been 85 I think it was
in 5 or 86 ready for one of those huge
oh yes I made a ton of money there Lord
way bigger I mean you think you made a
lot more but then they change it and
then you change it and it's only half of
what you got new beginnings similar to
that same tank Audi Mexico I've never
been there I'm scared to go there I
drove through it though oh I met this
cute little thing
knowing I can't speak their Spanish at
the time and I speak it almost fluently
but he wanted to go home so I'll try to
you
I drove him through Tijuana all the way
to Mexico de Fe where I couldn't go no
further the car blew up and he had to go
one way and I went together I called the
American consulate and they gave me the
money to get a ride back to TJ this was
actually during the time that the metros
here was on strike so I was stuck down
there at the Greyhound station and then
somebody for a watch gave me a ride out
to South Central
I've lived in South Central since I died
my quick game banging I've been many
many years was a crazy story
I asked the guy for some food he told me
tag me to McDonald's right around the
corner from where I'm living he pulled
over said he a chick is saying I'm a
turn to leave it was a man grabbed me by
the neck and tried to kill me if I had
not have rotated my body with the way he
was rotating my neck she would have
broken by the time I rotated my body I
got my knife out and I sliced his
[ __ ] ass so hard I know he had
had stitches but he wanted to hurt me I
will only use a weapon yet to hurt you
if I don't like liars of things I don't
do anything that I don't want done to me
anymore so I don't put out no bad karma
so if I did put something out to you and
you're watching I apologize I've changed
that's about it okay got it I know you
can talk I know I can ten minutes